- Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the Castle Lecture.
It's so wonderful to
see so many of you here.
Before I introduce our speaker
today, Kathleen Thelen,
I want to tell you a little bit
about this Castle Lecture series.
These are the signature speaker series
of the ethics, politics,
and economics major
at Yale University.
These lectures aim to promote awareness
of the ethical challenges and
complexities of societies,
and they're also meant
to foster robust dialogue
about the moral foundations
of society and government.
The series was established in 1988,
when Mr. Castle made a
generous gift to Yale
in honor of his ancestor,
Reverend James Pierpont,
who founded the college at
school of Connecticut in 1701.
This name might be familiar
because this school then became renamed
after its main benefactor,
Yale University.
So we're grateful to Mr.
Castle and his family
for the contribution to EP&E
and to Yale College more generally.
Our speaker today is Kathleen Thelen,
Ford Professor of
Political Science at MIT.
Her work focuses on the
origins and evolution
of political economic
institutions in rich democracies,
and she's the author among others
of Varieties of Liberalization
and the New Politics of Social Solidarity,
How Institutions Evolve,
and she's co-editor of
American Political Economy:
Politics, Markets, and Power.
During her career she
has received many awards
for her insightful work.
And because of time constraints,
I'm not gonna go through the whole list,
I'm just gonna mention a
few of the most recent ones.
She was awarded
the Aaron Wildavsky
Enduring Contribution Prize,
the Michael Endres Research Prize,
the Barrington Moore Book Prize,
the Woodrow Wilson
Foundation Award of the APSR
among many others.
She holds honorary degrees
at the Free University of Amsterdam, LSC,
the European University
Institute in Florence,
and the University of Copenhagen.
Professor Thelen has served as President
of the American Political
Science Association.
She has also been Chair of the
Council for European Studies
and the President of the
Society for the Advancement
of Social Economics.
She was awarded, sorry,
she was elected to the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences
and to the Berlin-Brandenburg
Academy of Sciences.
Finally, she's a key figure
in the Consortium of
American Political Economy,
recent network of scholars
that examine the United
States' distinctive mix
of capitalism and democracy.
And fitting with the consortium
mission, in today's talk,
we're gonna hear about
American retail capitalism
and the origins of the Amazon economy.
The format of this lecture
will be that Professor Thelen
will speak for about 50 minutes,
and then we're gonna open up for questions
from the audience.
So please join me in
welcoming Professor Thelen.
(audience applauds)
- So I wanna first begin by saying
that this is a tremendous honor
to have been asked to
deliver the Castle Lecture.
I wanna thank my Yale
colleagues for the invitation.
I wanna thank John Castle and his family,
in absentia unfortunately,
for sponsoring and
supporting this whole series
and all of you for coming today to listen.
So I became interested in
American retail capitalism
as I was watching this kind
of ferociously ambitious
retail entrepreneur
who was engaged in a
really aggressive strategy
of relentless expansion,
offering convenient at-home shopping
for a kind of ever
widening range of products,
while also maintaining very low prices
because of this huge sales
volume that this was generating.
So this company's success,
of course, provoked antipathy
among the small independent merchants
who really couldn't match
the sort of large inventory
and especially low cost
of this retail giant.
You also had critics complaining
that this company's profits
were being underwritten by taxpayers
because of the central role
that the US Postal System
was playing in delivering
these goods to customers.
Meanwhile, the firm's employees,
virtually all of them
of course un-unionized,
were bearing the brunt of
this really monotonous,
but also kind of frantically paced work
in state-of-the-art warehouses
deploying the latest technologies.
Suppliers to this company felt squeezed
and trapped in a relationship
of unequal dependence, right?
They were relying on this outlet
to get their goods to their customers.
But customers, well,
customers were smitten
because now they had the
luxury of shopping from home,
choosing from this really wide selection
of every imaginable product
all at unbeatable prices,
with money back guarantees
and special perks for loyal customers,
and everything delivered
right to their door.
And if you think that
I'm talking about Amazon,
you would actually be wrong
because the company that I'm describing
is actually Sears and Roebuck circa 1908.
So it was these parallels
between the business
strategies of Amazon today
and those of Sears over a century ago
that really sparked my interest
in retail capitalism in the United States.
Okay, so I'm a comparativist,
I'm a Europeanist,
but the American case is really important
for students of the political economy
of the rich democracies, like myself,
because the US is really seen
as the kind of quintessential
consumer society.
Consumption and, by extension, retailing
is just widely recognized
as absolutely critical
to sustaining this country's
demand-driven growth model.
So it turns out that
retailing and distribution
is a substantively very important sector
across really all the rich democracies.
It accounts for between 10 and 15%
of jobs across really
all the OECD countries,
which actually puts it very
close to manufacturing.
It's even higher in the United States.
As you see, in 2003, the
number of Americans working
in retail actually
surpassed the number working
in factories.
And in the last couple of decades,
retail really passed manufacturing.
It's kind of the leading
force in economic growth
in the United States.
So in terms of employment,
large discount retailers specifically
are, by really big margins,
the biggest employers
in the United States.
And big retailers, as you see here,
really just don't play the
same sort of central role
in employment in other countries.
And even though European retailing
has been kind of moving
toward the American model
on some dimensions, I
think it's fair to say
that the US really still stands
out in some important ways.
First off, as you see in this figure,
as I hope you can see,
the US just has way more
retail space per capita
than Europe.
And that's a function, of course,
of these huge shopping
centers that you find
in most American suburbs.
What you see on the right here
is the famous Mall of
America in Minnesota,
which has over 500 stores and
over 20,000 parking spots.
But the outsized presence
of these retailers
is also a function of these
big box discount retailers
like Target and Walmart
that are really ubiquitous
in the United States.
According to Forbes, 90%
of Americans actually live
within 15 minutes of a Walmart.
And of course these places
are basically always open.
So one of the biggest
differences to Europe
is that shopping hours are
simply far more regulated
in most European countries.
And then last but not least,
these huge low cost retailers
are actually really popular
in the United States.
So this is, on the left
is the results of a survey
from 2019, which shows that, you know,
Amazon counted as
America's best loved brand.
And as you see, a lot of
these other big risk retailers
are not very far behind.
On the right, I confess that's
not the most scientific study
in the world, but basically when asked,
you know, which companies they love,
usually Germans are gonna
go for their car companies.
So the central role played by retail
and these big discount retailers,
specifically within the US,
seemed to be one of the
most distinctive features
of the American political economy.
And so I set out to try to
explain how we got here.
So what do we know about
the politics of retailing?
There's really a lot
of, I would say, wonderful
work on consumer culture
and on consumer credit
mostly by economic historians,
also by sociologists,
but almost all of this work
is focused on a particular slice of time,
namely the post World War II period.
And most of this work, or
almost none of this work,
is on retail, it's on
consumption and consumers,
but not on retail specifically,
which is my focus.
So economists and management scholars
who have studied retail
have tended towards sort
of apolitical explanations
for the success of these
mega retailers, right?
It's a story about the size
of the American market,
about technological or
organizational innovations
on the part of these kind
of brilliant entrepreneurs
that allowed these companies
to grow to dominance.
Chandler would be kind
of the classic on this,
but there are also more recent
examples of this as well.
So, unsurprisingly, I'm
a political scientist.
The argument that I've
developed is more political.
I wanna argue that mass
retailers in the United States
were not simply responding
to market opportunities.
They were creating them,
and they were creating them
by exploiting regulatory gaps
as they grew in scale and scope.
So legal scholars
have offered a somewhat
more political version
of the story of the rise
of these big retailers.
So there's, of course, this
seminal article by Lina Khan,
who is well known here at Yale,
and who is now, of course, as you know,
the head of the Federal Trade Commission.
And she attributed the rise of Amazon,
in particular to the ascendants
of the so-called Chicago
School of Law and Economics
starting basically in the
'60s and especially '70s.
And this is a school of thought
that put consumer welfare,
defined essentially as price,
at the center of American antitrust theory
and jurisprudence.
There's a couple of spots
up here, if you like.
So clearly the rise of the Chicago school
has been very important.
And as you're gonna hear,
antitrust actually plays a really big role
in the explanation that
I've been developing.
But where I part ways
with at least that strand
of legal scholarship,
is that I wanna show that
the changes of the 1960s
are actually really
just the latest chapter
in what is in fact a much longer story,
one in which large retailers
have basically always enjoyed,
an extraordinarily privileged position
within the American antitrust regime.
So finally, comparative
political economists,
for their part, really
haven't had that much at all
to say about the politics of retail
or distribution generally.
The focus of almost all of this work,
and I include my own, no,
I include my own here,
is just overwhelmingly on
the politics of production.
So to the extent
that comparative political
economists like myself
have addressed these questions,
it's a literature that focuses not so much
on the politics of retailing
but on consumer credit
and especially the
expansion of consumer credit
in the US in response
to the Great Depression.
Again, this is clearly important,
but what I wanna argue is
that the focus on credit
has really tended to obscure the role
of these large discount retailers
that always stayed away from credit sales,
but that I think have had a huge impact,
not just on the American retail landscape,
but on the American
political economy as a whole.
So this project traces the origins
of what I'm calling the Amazon
economy all the way back
to the late 19th century.
This is a period when these
large scale retailers begin
to capitalize on what I see
as a uniquely permissive
regulatory landscape in the US
to basically outgrow the capacity
of the government to regulate them.
So two features of the American
political economy figure
especially prominently in the explanation
that I've been developing.
The first is the role of
the American judiciary
and an antitrust regime
that, as I wanna say,
from the beginning, gave mass
retailers enormous advantages
and in ways that were
completely distinct from Europe.
And second is regulatory fragmentation.
And here I basically mean a
political economic landscape
that assigned most of
the regulatory powers
to state and local governments,
which turned out to be no match
for these large retailers,
who, you know, based not
least on the head start
that they had received from the courts,
were quickly operating
on a national scale.
So the argument in a nutshell
is that judicial forbearance
and regulatory arbitrage
allowed large American retailers
to grow.
And as they grew, they were able
to win over an ever expanding
political support coalition
of groups who, over time,
came to rely on these big
companies in various ways.
And then of course, these
groups could then be weaponized
to defend these companies
in their political battles
with would-be regulators.
So this is a study that
tries to cover more
than 100 years of retail development.
I'm not gonna give you a sort
of blow by blow
comprehensive treatment here,
but instead what I wanna do
in this talk is just zoom in
on a couple of the key
junctures on the screen here,
where these dynamics played out
and where, as I wanna show,
the politics unfolded very
differently from Europe.
So the first period, if you will,
is the construction of the mass market
in the late 19th century.
This is a period where
these mail order retailers
played an enormously important role.
The second is the growth
of mass consumption.
In the 1920s, this is the period
that saw really the explosion
of chain store retailing.
And the third period is the
post World War II period
that saw the rise to dominance
of these big box discount retailers.
So circling back,
starting with the
construction of a mass market.
So, you know, in the late 19th century,
there was no mass market,
not in Europe, not in the United States.
Basically what you had everywhere
is merchants scattered all over the place.
Each of these merchants
carried very limited selection,
to say the least.
They charged very high prices,
partly because they were at the end
of very long supply chains,
but also partly because each
of them, of course, operated
as a kind of local monopoly
within their little area.
So in Europe, consumer co-ops emerged
to challenge these small merchants,
and they grew to become
the first mass retailers.
So you'd have farmers or
workers who would join together
to pool resources in
order to get better prices
by purchasing in high volume
and then sell directly to members.
These local cooperatives
would then scale up
by developing ties to
cooperatives in other regions,
sort of the other localities and regions,
sort of growing from bottom up and out
until they grew to national,
in some cases international scale.
So this was happening throughout Europe,
most famously, I would
say, in Scandinavia,
where cooperatives are
actually still major players
in the retail landscape.
But actually the earliest
and most successful example
of this emerged in what is
America's closest cousin,
namely Britain.
And this took the form of the
cooperative wholesale society,
which grew out of these
local cooperatives,
but that really took off
after legislation in the 1850s
and especially '60s, allowed
individual cooperatives
to coordinate their activities, okay?
And so that is what
allowed for the formation
of a national society, a
co-op of co-ops, if you will,
that became, you know, grew to
become the biggest retailer,
not just in Britain, but in the world
by the end of the 19th century.
And then as in other countries,
this national cooperative association
in Britain also then
began integrating backward
in order to start
producing some of the goods
that they sold.
And so what you see on the right here
is one of their production facilities.
So similar cooperative ventures
were also getting founded in the US
in the late 19th century.
So some of you of course will
know about the Grange movement
and its successor the, Farmer's Alliance.
These were important in American history
as the main organizations
that farmers developed
to advance both their economic interests,
but also to channel their
political grievances.
And these were, of course, associations
that became hugely important
in the populist revolt
against monopoly power
in the late 19th century.
So starting in the 1860s,
these local Grange chapters
organize themselves
into cooperatives, both to
try to secure higher prices
for their own goods, but
also to try to pool orders
to secure lower costs for their
members on consumer goods.
Unlike in Europe though, these
efforts were not really met
by state support or even forbearance,
in fact, even as cooperatives in Europe
were really flourishing in this period.
They failed to thrive and
grow in the United States.
And one of the bigger
obstacles that they faced
was this fragmented and fractured
and far less congenial legal landscape.
So it's a complicated story,
but the short version of the
story is that unlike in Europe,
there was no national legislation
in the late 19th century
that could clarify the legal
standing of these cooperatives,
and that expressly
sanctioned their activities.
This was getting decided in the courts.
And while courts in some
states saw no problem
with these cooperatives,
especially starting in the 1880s,
courts in other states began
to view the kind of joint marketing
and distribution that
really stood at the center
of the cooperative
project as price fixing,
and thus running afoul
of common law prohibitions
against conspiracies
in restraint of trade.
So at this point, sometimes
state legislatures
would step in and pass a law trying
to exempt these cooperatives
from prosecution,
but federal courts often took
a pretty hard line on this
and struck down some of these state laws
as unconstitutional, either
on grounds of equal protection
or after the Sherman
Antitrust Act of 1890,
as violations of federal antitrust laws.
And this is of course paradoxical
because these agrarian interests
had provided a great deal of the impetus
behind the Sherman Antitrust Act,
which was supposed to be
directed against the JP Morgans
and Rockefellers of the world,
but which often came to be deployed
against their own
cooperative associations.
So the failure of those ventures
then provided a huge opening
for private corporations
to basically move into this space,
because individual companies
that organized all these marketing
and distribution functions internally
were of course outside the
scope of these antitrust laws.
There's no collusion, no conspiracy
if you're within a single
private entity or company.
So Montgomery Ward was
really the first one
to kind of open the vast consumer markets
of the American West and South,
but it was this guy, Richard Warren Sears,
who really came to dominate this market.
And so he moved in
with an extraordinarily
aggressive strategy
of very high volume sales,
very thin margins, very low prices,
and on a really insanely
wide range of products.
So when it was founded in 1886,
the Sears catalog, if you
wanna call it a catalog,
was just a one page flyer.
All he sold was watches.
But within just 20
years, just two decades,
this catalog was 1,000s of pages long.
You could literally buy
everything from toothbrushes
to entire prefabricated houses
that would come to you
with all the millwork done
and, you know, sort of instructions
for how to reassemble them, right?
So it's sort of like
ordering an IKEA chair
or something like that.
Some of these Sears houses
are actually still standing
in the American Midwest.
Many of them are in
Illinois, you can visit them.
So the expansion of these
companies across the US
would not have been possible
had it not been for the
way in which they were able
to exploit existing public infrastructure
for private purposes.
And here the US Postal System
played an absolutely critical role
because this is what
provided these companies,
not just with a subsidized
means of getting their catalogs
and their goods to this widely
dispersed rural population,
but also, I would say,
much more importantly,
local post offices were able to serve
as a critical intermediary
in the financial transactions
that these companies were
having with their customers.
So, as I said, in Europe,
these cooperatives
had grown kind of from the
bottom up and out, right,
through Federation.
So they had local branches
all over the place.
They could sell things for cash
or they could let people run a tab.
Montgomery Ward and Sears, of course,
by definition did not have retail outlets.
And moreover, virtually all
of their rural customers were unbanked.
They had no bank accounts,
they were operating basically
on a cash or barter economy.
So how are you going to do
these long distance sales?
Well, you could of course
send cash through the mail,
but it, which as you know,
if you've seen American Westerns,
stage coaches were constantly getting,
you know, that were carrying the mail
were constantly getting held up,
which is why this guy has
his hands up in the air.
So none of this actually
would have been possible
without the money order system
that the US Postal system offered.
So this was a service
that the government
had introduced earlier,
and for completely different reasons,
in the Civil War, in order to
allow union soldiers basically
to get their money back home safely.
But these retailers were able
to repurpose this service
to serve as a critical
financial intermediary
in their transactions with customers.
And just to give you a sense
of how much a company
like Sears, for example,
depended on the infrastructure
of the US Postal System,
here are the instructions from
a Sears catalog from 1908.
It says, "if you live
on a rural mail route,
just give the letter and the
money to the mail carrier
and he will get the money
order at the post office
and mail it in the letter for you."
So this is how America's
first mass retailers
were able to reach and win
over millions of customers
who now had access to this unlimited range
of standardized consumer goods
and at prices their local
merchants could not hope to match.
And once they had this loyal,
I would say, more or less
captive consumer base,
they could also mobilize them
as a powerful ally in
their political battles.
And one of the most
important of those battles
was to secure legislation
to expand postal services
to carry more and bigger packages.
So parcel post.
This is something that's
obviously of clear value to Sears,
but very much opposed both
by the big express companies
that you otherwise had to pay
to transport all those goods
and buy the small merchants that Sears
was, of course, putting out
of business at this time.
So when legislation on parcel
post was being considered,
mass retailers actively
weaponize their rural consumers
among other ways, encouraging them
to basically blanket Congress
with petitions, which they did.
And so what you see on the right here
is that petitions in favor
of parcel post spiked
at precisely the moments
when Congress was considering legislation
to fund this service.
And those were coming
from exactly these areas.
So when it came time for the vote,
virtually all of the support
that carried this legislation
came from Democrats
in the rural south and west,
which is what you see
in the dark blue here.
These were exactly the areas
that relied virtually entirely
on mail order companies
in order to link them
into this national market.
Parcel posts then ushered
in a kind of golden age
of mail order.
Sears saw its sales increase fivefold
in just the first year of parcel post.
Montgomery Ward, as you
see, was not far behind.
So in this first period,
these large mail order companies
enjoyed extremely favorable treatment
under American antitrust,
they proceeded to grow by exploiting
and repurposing public
infrastructure for private ends.
And American farmers, of course,
who otherwise were battling big business,
they did not battle these companies.
They in fact welcomed them with open arms
because it liberated them
from these high priced local markets,
bringing them a kind of world
of exotic new consumer goods.
This then sets the scene
for the explosive growth
of these chain stores in
the early 20th century.
So the early 20th century
and the inner war period,
the progressive era and
the so-called roaring '20s,
is this really paradoxical
period in American history,
one that was characterized simultaneously
by high and rising inequality,
both wealth inequality,
which is in the blue
or kind of green here,
and income inequality.
But it was also a period
that saw a real boom
in consumption and consumer spending.
So Americans were buying
things like washing machines
and vacuum cleaners really decades
before their counterparts in Europe.
So how did the average
American get all this stuff?
Part of the answer is that
established retailers,
which by now of course includes Sears,
they were already
selling things on credit.
And that's another story
of regulatory arbitrage
that I try to tell in the book.
Basically the expansion of consumer credit
in this period expanded
really in a legal gray zone,
very much sort of under the radar.
And I can talk more about
that in the Q&A, if you like.
The other development though,
that fueled consumption
in the 1920s was the
really phenomenal growth
of chain stores which operated
on a cash only basis, okay?
So you had new entrants
to the retail sector,
Woolworths, JCPenney, Ben Franklin.
They did not offer credit.
They were competing exclusively on price.
So these chains grew
extraordinarily rapidly
in just these 10 years.
So just 10 years.
I put some figures on the
screen just to give you a sense
of the explosion of these
chain stores in this period.
What you also see at
the bottom of the screen
is that the numbers in
Europe are much lower.
So where variety chains
already were accounting
for nearly a quarter of
retail turnover in the US,
they were only accounting
for 7% in England
and under 2% in other
countries on the continent.
And this was in large part
because these kinds of operations
were encountering much
stiffer headwinds in Europe.
In other words, the politics
were, again, playing out very differently
on the other side of the Atlantic.
So these conflicts centered on two issues.
One was resale price
maintenance arrangements
and the other was special
taxes on large retailers.
And I just wanna talk
briefly about each of these
in order to underscore the differences
to Europe at the time.
So resale price maintenance
arrangements involve contracts
through which manufacturers
commit retailers
to charge a specific, usually
minimum price for their goods.
So this is promoted by
manufacturers of patented goods
who wanna protect the
reputation of their brands,
but, of course, small retailers
also love these arrangements
because if everybody had
to charge the same price,
this would relieve them
of price competition from these larger,
more efficient producers.
So in that sense, resale price
maintenance kind of reflected
or maybe created a kind of alliance
between brand manufacturers
and small merchants, on one hand,
against these larger low cost
retailers who at the time
were already advocating specifically,
explicitly the right for
what they call the right
to cut prices.
So resale price maintenance
contracts were perfectly legal
and indeed widespread in
Europe throughout this period,
throughout the interwar period
and indeed well into the
post World War II period.
Mostly they survived until the 1960s.
In Germany, resale price maintenance
was only banned in 1974.
And this too goes back to
this different approach
to competition policy,
because unlike in the US,
courts in Europe in the early 20th century
were adhering to the principle
of freedom of contract
but including recognizing contracts
that, under American law,
would've been considered anti-competitive.
So resale price maintenance
arrangements were not just legal
in European coordinated market economies,
this you might expect,
but also in Britain,
again, a fellow liberal market economy
and also one that shares
America's common law tradition.
So the organizational vehicle
through which these arrangements operated
was the British Proprietary
Articles Trade Association.
This was founded in 1896,
and this was an outfit that
brought together manufacturers,
wholesalers, and retailers
who jointly administered
and policed a list of protected
prices on trademarked goods.
So what I'm about to describe
would've been 100% illegal in the US,
but the way it worked
is that manufacturers set their prices,
retailers would then monitor those prices,
they would notify the association
if some retailer was found to
be undercutting that price,
and then the association
would collectively enforce
the manufacturer's price
by putting that retailer
on a so-called stop list.
And being on the stop list,
then obliged all other association members
to stop supplying that firm
or that retailer.
So small independent retailers
were beneficiaries of this
because this channeled retail competition
in Britain away from price
and toward competition centering more
on quality and on service.
So the situation in the US
was radically different.
From very early on,
starting at the latest in
1911, the Supreme Court ruled
that resale price maintenance arrangements
were, per se, illegal
under prevailing antitrust.
And the landmark case here
was one that pitted a
large discount drugstore,
a price cutter, against
a small manufacturer
of patented medicine.
And in this case, the court ruled
in favor of the big drug chain,
basically giving retailers control
over the prices they charged.
So this case was controversial.
It inspired the formation of
a so-called Fair Trade League
that advocated changes in antitrust law
to try to allow smaller firms
to engage in greater coordination,
to protect themselves from domination
by these larger entities,
especially to steer
competition away from price
and toward innovation and quality.
So the Fair Trade League had
some very prominent advocates,
including future Supreme
Court Justice Louis Brandeis,
among others.
And Brandeis was actually well aware
of what was happening in Europe,
and he really admired some of the aspects
of the alternative model
of what he called regulated competition
that he saw developing there at the time.
So he and other progressives saw this ban
on resale price maintenance
as really just encouraging
ruinous price competition.
He called it competition that kills.
This would inspire a race to the bottom,
it would lead to monopoly,
especially because it would kill off all
of these smaller innovative competitors.
But American Free Traders
were really quite stymied
in the courts really throughout the 1920s.
In other words, precisely
through that period,
which as I just pointed out,
was when these chain stores
were experiencing their
most explosive growth.
So the situation changed a little bit
in the early 1930s.
Now we're in the midst
of the Great Depression.
Brandeis is, by this time,
of course on the bench,
and the Supreme Court did relax
what rules states could pass in this area.
And some states, in fact many states,
did pass fair trade legislation.
But very different from Europe,
brand manufacturers
could still not legally
and openly enlist the help
of other retailers or other producers
in defending the prices that they set.
That would still be illegal.
So enforcement ran entirely
through private litigation.
And private litigation was
extraordinarily expensive
for most firms, and it was
certainly too expensive
for most of the small firms that Brandeis
and others had really sought to protect.
Just to give you one
example, at one point,
General Electric was pursuing
3000 different lawsuits
against various companies
for violating its contracts,
which is a huge legal expense
these small companies couldn't match.
Moreover, state laws, of course,
only cover intra-state trade.
So this did not really stop these chains
that had now grown to national scale
and that could engage
in regulatory arbitrage,
basically switching up their sourcing
in order to avoid fair trade states
or just buying the entire
output of a single supplier.
So chain store age, which was
and still is actually the
main chain store magazine,
was constantly publishing tips
on how to work around these laws.
So basically too little
and arguably too late.
Running parallel to all of these battles
over resale price maintenance
during the depression
were other efforts to slow
down the chains in other ways.
And this took the form of efforts
to impose heavy taxes on chain stores.
This is, again, something
that small retailers
would've loved to see.
And so what you have on the screen here
is just to kind of sample
of some of the rhetoric
of the time.
These guys are, you know,
vicious price cutters.
They're running legitimate
retailers out of business.
They're callous foreign entities
that don't contribute
anything to the local economy.
So a lot of these campaigns
against the chains
were really pretty successful,
particularly in the south
and, yeah, south and west.
And this is because this
was coming at a time
when these small variety
chains were moving in
and really placing a lot of
pressure on local businesses,
businesses that were in
the depression, of course,
already suffering from the downturn.
It's also the depression.
And so populism is enjoying
a renaissance at this point.
You have people, you
know, Wall Street bankers
are being blamed for the depression.
You have populace like Huey Long saying,
"I would rather have thieves and gangsters
than chain stores in Louisiana."
So in fact chain store
taxes did get passed
in many of these, or in some
of these states at least.
But again, they ran into
trouble in the courts,
certainly in the 1920s,
when chain store taxes
were getting struck down, again,
on equal protection grounds
under the 14th Amendment.
And even when these taxes
were not getting struck down,
chains were just engaging
in the same sorts
of regulatory arbitrage,
sort of reorganizing their operations
in order to avoid these taxes
or to minimize their
obligations under them.
So state level regulation
was clearly ineffective.
And so this all culminated
in 1938 in one big,
I would say, kind of last ditch effort
to impose a chain store
tax at the national level.
And that was an effort that
was spearheaded by this guy,
Texas Representative Wright Patman,
who some people have called
America's last populist.
But his proposal for this
national chain store tax
really went down in flames
because by this time,
chains were able to mobilize their allies
in huge public relations campaigns.
So they did things like sponsor referenda
in order to mobilize voters.
And so on the right here, you
see just an example of this.
This is from a referendum in Utah,
where basically the chains are saying,
you know, if you put taxes on us
or if you raise taxes on us,
that's simply going to result
in higher prices for you.
So by the time things,
you know, by the time it came time
to consider Patman's legislation,
a whole bunch of groups kind
of came out of the woodwork
to defend the chains.
So you had farmers and farm
organizations turning out
in the congressional
hearings to defend the chains
because in the meantime,
they had come to depend
on these grocery chains
as an efficient way
to distribute their products
and also especially to
unload periodic surpluses,
which was of course a big
problem for American farmers.
You had manufacturers,
even the manufacturers
who had previously fought
the chains on prices,
now they climbed on board
because they were, of course,
extremely capital intensive.
And so now this economic
downturn had sort of taught them
to appreciate the kind
of predict predictability
that these large retailers provided
because they ordered in very large volume
and well in advance.
And finally, you know,
consumers were basically hooked
on the chains.
Consumers in the US have
historically been represented
by women's clubs, by women's groups.
And so women's groups also turned out
in the congressional
hearings to defend the chains
as a kind of go-to source
for low cost goods.
So by the late 1930s,
already just a few years
after it had gotten going,
this chain store taxation
movement was now kind of spent.
Now you had states repealing
their chain store taxes.
Now in fact you had states often competing
to have these lower cost retailers locate
in their jurisdictions.
And so this is an article
from the New York Times from 1939.
Here's a national survey
that was fielded in 1938,
just when this national chain store tax
was being considered
and people were asked,
well, what do you think
would be the best policy
toward the chain stores?
And basically what you see here
is that now most Americans thought
that they should be left alone
to "make what profits they can
rather than tax them extra."
And certainly not to get
rid of them entirely,
which had been Patman's objective there.
So, again, the politics of
retailing in the 1920s and '30s
in the US were really strikingly
different from Europe.
Large retailers had already benefited
from this enormous headstart
by virtue of this ban on
resale price maintenance.
And once they were operating
on a national scale,
they were able to really work
around whatever state laws
were getting it passed in this fractured,
fragmented regulatory landscape.
And again, as they grew,
they were assembling
this ever expanding kind
of support coalition
that they were mobilizing
whenever they faced a
new regulatory threat.
So finally, and very briefly
to the post World War II period,
this is of course the period
that saw the kind of full flowering
of America's consumption
driven growth model.
This is the period that's really famous
for the boom in consumption
largely as a result of
government-sponsored housing loans,
at least for white middle class families.
This is the period that saw the growth
of these suburbs and these suburban malls
that I was talking about at the beginning.
But even as these new
suburban shopping centers
were reconfiguring the
geography of shopping,
you had disruptive new
entrance to the retail sector
that would really redefine
the temporal bounds
of shopping as well.
So as I mentioned at the outset,
despite some liberalization,
really in general,
shopping hours in Europe
are simply a lot more regulated
than they are in the United States.
You have shorter days,
but also in particular,
you have a lot more
restrictions on Sunday shopping.
And actually that was the
case in the US as well.
Sunday shopping was really not a thing
in the immediate post World War II years.
Shops were generally closed.
But all of this started
falling apart in the 1960s
with the arrival of these very
disruptive new discounters.
So you had a bunch of
kind of small operations
that flamed out pretty quickly.
Those are the ones on the left,
like, Korvettes was one of
the most famous of these.
But this is also the period
that saw the founding
of some of these bigger,
more durable chains.
And so Kmart and Walmart and
Target, all three of those
were actually founded in
the same year, in 1962.
And all of these discounters,
they were challenging
established retailers,
not just on price,
though, of course, absolutely on price,
but also simply by
staying open both evenings
and also on Sundays,
which at the time, again, was not a thing.
So, again, small retailers
and their allies mobilized
to try to impose some restrictions here.
They were joined by
religious groups often,
they were actually also joined
by some of the big department stores
because department stores of
course had higher staffing
and therefore higher labor costs
and they weren't interested
in having the extended hours.
But again, you get the same basic story.
Again, you have a flurry of
state and local legislation
that attempts to regulate Sunday selling.
These laws took a variety of tax.
Some of them tried to ban the sale
of items other than necessities.
Some of them tried to limit Sunday selling
to particular kinds of retailers.
Some of them tried to
prohibit only big stores
from staying open on Sundays.
But even where these laws were passed,
these discounters often just
flagrantly ignored the rules
and simply paid the fines.
They were basically
absorbing these legal costs
as just another business expense.
It reminds me very much of the way
that Uber entered local
transportation markets.
Basically, Uber just came in,
in the US at least, ignored
local transportation laws
and simply paid the fines
while they scaled up.
So in Europe, this kind of rule breaking
met with the opposition,
not just of small merchants,
but also of religious groups and unions.
But in the US, where
unions were much weaker,
enforcement tended to
run through the courts.
And when these things got litigated,
retailers actually often won.
And they were able to prevail often
because they could claim a
discriminatory treatment,
which met with a lot of
sympathy in US courts
because they have often strong aversions
to any kind of government intervention
that might smack of
legislative favoritism.
Most importantly though,
while these cases dragged on,
these stores just stayed open
and the people got used to it.
And once they got used to
it, they wanted to keep it.
And so here's a survey from the mid 1970s
which asks, again, a
national survey asking,
"how would you feel about
a law against stores
being open on Sundays?"
And as you see here,
a huge majority by this time opposed that.
And even actually when state laws did say,
yes, you may try to legislate
or you may try to restrict Sunday hours,
basically enforcement
was just a huge problem.
You know, who were the
police supposed to arrest,
shoppers, managers?
It just wasn't clear.
So all of this kind of
culminated in an important case
before the New York Circuit,
New York Court of Appeals
that throughout a state
law that had been trying
to limit Sunday shopping hours,
and the court did so
based on the observation
that those laws seemed to be incoherent,
they seemed to be unenforceable.
And this was dangerous
because this encouraged
what the court considered
to be an erosive disrespect of the law.
So over the next years, basically
what happened is that all
of these states abandoned
their legal prohibitions,
either explicitly
or more often they just
stopped enforcing them.
And this is how we ended
up with this uniquely,
sort of compared to
other rich democracies,
a uniquely unregulated
shopping hour regime
that we have today.
So I wanna forego the
usual kind of conclusion.
And so instead I want
to wrap up this talk,
not by sort of repeating the argument
or by summarizing the
argument, but by stepping back
and sort of panning out a little bit
to highlight the significance
of these developments
for the American political
economy as a whole.
And I wanna also try to situate this study
in the context of some of my previous work
on inequality and particularly inequality
at the low income,
at the low end of the income ladder.
So one of the reasons that I
think it's really important
to think about the evolution
of discount retailing specifically,
alongside the other sort of, I think,
much better known story
of the role of credit
within the post-war
American political economy
is that it gives us a
somewhat different angle
on the crisis of American manufacturing
and on rising inequality
in the US since the 1970s.
So as I've tried to point out
in some of my previous work
on labor and labor markets,
one of the ways in which
the US really stands out
in international comparisons
is for the really large
size of the low pay sector.
And so what you see on the
screen here are OECD figures
on the share of low pay,
the size of the low pay
sector as a percentage
of the full workforce.
Low pay here defined as
earning less than two thirds
of median income.
And what you see is that
the US is at the high end
among its peers.
The same story or much
the same story is true
if you look at in-work poverty.
I don't have the comparative figures,
but I just looked at the most
recent figures for the US,
which is from 2021, that
show that nearly 15%
of Americans live in households
with incomes below 60% of
median disposable income.
And to put that in perspective,
the OECD average is 9.3%.
So, again, very much at the high end.
Beyond that, and again,
as I've tried to point out
in some of my other work,
these low paid jobs in the
US really just don't come
with a lot of the benefits
that are taken for
granted in Europe, right?
Healthcare benefits,
there is, in this country,
no federally guaranteed paid time off.
There is, in this country,
no federally guaranteed vacation days.
There's no rules regarding scheduling.
And so precarious workers in
particular are often subject
to extraordinarily irregular,
unstable work hours.
These are all ways in which the US
is an enormous outlier in
international perspective.
And these types of precarious
working relationships
have really grown
especially since the 1970s.
So a common, you know, not
unreasonable explanation
for that is the decline
of American manufacturing
in the face of, you know,
competition from lower
cost producers abroad.
And that's of course what's seen
as having destroyed all these kind
of better paid unionized
manufacturing jobs.
And that's what left us
with a lot of low skill,
low pay service sector jobs.
That account is of course not wrong,
but I think it's radically incomplete
because in that model,
the pressures on American manufacturing
are entirely exogenous.
You know, American retailers are not seen
as having played any particular role here.
They're just seen as some kind
of a passive transmission belt.
These stores are just
offering consumers a choice
and consumers are going
for the lower prices.
But in the story that I'm trying to tell,
these large low cost retailers
are really playing a much more active role
in accelerating the decline
of American manufacturing
and undermining the American
growth model more generally.
I think it's really important
that the factors that I'm
trying to highlight here,
this legal regime and the
fractured regulatory landscape,
that promoted a particular
model of retailing to dominance.
It's an ultra lean retailing model.
It's based on extremely narrow margins,
is dominated by big players,
Walmart, now Amazon,
that enjoy enormous power,
both over workers and
over their suppliers.
So of course these companies,
one of the things that they're doing
is that they're cutting their
own labor costs to the bone.
And as you see here,
that's a very old recipe.
That goes all the way back
to, you know, Frank Woolworth,
who in 1892 already was
saying, we must have cheap help
or we can't sell cheap goods.
And as you see, I put some figures here,
as you see, retail workers
in the US themselves make
up a very significant share
of this American precarious
that I was talking about.
Over three quarters of them
fall in that low wage category
that I just showed you.
Fully 15% of them qualify for Medicaid.
According to a recent study,
2022 study from the Government
Accountability Office,
Amazon and especially Walmart
are among the top employers
whose workers depend on SNAP benefits,
what we used to call food stamps.
Beyond their own labor model though,
these dominant discounters
have also been extraordinarily aggressive,
enforcing the manufacturers
and the vendors who supply them
to accept ever narrower margins
and therefore to cut their own costs.
So Walmart is of course famous for its,
you know, using its dominance
to extract extremely low
prices from its suppliers,
many of whom rely really very heavily
on this single company for a huge share
of their total sales.
And these are pressures,
of course, that, you know,
in the 1970s, these producers
began passing on to workers,
you know, first by moving
to the non-union South
and later by outsourcing or subcontracting
with lower cost producers abroad.
And similarly today, of course Amazon
is able to extract really high fees
from many of the third party sellers
who are literally existentially reliant
on this platform in order
to reach their customers.
And what makes these
companies hard to regulate,
especially in the US, is
that just as in the past,
all the while they're actively
cultivating this large,
loyal customer base.
So prime membership globally
is now up to about 200 million,
more than three quarters
of them are Americans.
That may be not so surprising,
it's an American company,
but what did surprise me
is that fully two-thirds
of all online shoppers
in the United States,
and that's a lot of people,
are Amazon Prime members.
So you begin to get a
kind of normalization
of these relationships
and growing popularity
as more and more people
come to kind of depend
on these services and start to think
that it's perfectly normal to
expect these low priced goods
to be delivered to their door
by many of these precarious workers
that I was just talking about,
delivered within, used to
be 48 hours, now is 24,
increasingly it's, in some
places, same day service.
And then once you're in this
cycle of, you know, low margins
and low wages, you also then
begin to have this population
of low income workers who rely
on these low cost retailers
to make ends meet, right?
So in this context, these
large discount retailers
have paradoxically kind of
become part of the infrastructure
of the lives of many citizens
and not just for the low
prices that they offer, right?
For people like me
or probably most of the
people in this room,
who have, you know, pretty
good pay, very flexible jobs,
you know, we may prefer to
shop at our local stores,
that's my local bookstore
on the left there,
but for people with low incomes,
people who work really long
hours, sometimes two jobs,
people who have no paid
time off, no vacation days,
and certainly can't pay
the high cost of daycare,
for people like that,
and that's a really
large share of Americans,
it's not an option
necessarily to shop around
at a lot of smaller specialty stores.
It may seem more realistic just
to go to some big box store
at whatever time of night and day
and buy everything you need
at this low price kind of all in one go.
Finally, it's not just consumers
who have come to rely
on these big retailers.
So when the pandemic hit, you know,
European countries mobilized
their healthcare infrastructure
in order to administer vaccines, right?
In the US what happened, in
the US the government turned
to these big retailers,
CVS, Walgreens, and Walmart,
as kind of a key part of
the essential infrastructure
to vaccinate the public.
So Walmart played a really central role
in reaching rural communities
that are otherwise completely underserved
by the American healthcare system.
They played a big role in
reaching low income groups
that, again, lack the paid
time off that you might need
to visit a clinic during the day.
You could go to Walmart at
10:00 PM and get your shot.
These are things that Americans
kind of take for granted
or don't think that much about,
but they are highly
anomalous to Europeans.
I mean, my European friends
were shocked to hear
that I got one of my
shots at a Walmart, right?
So my point is absolutely not
to celebrate these big discounters.
I hope I've made eminently clear
that I'm a critic particularly
of their labor model.
I just wanna point out
that the US is in a very
deep equilibrium here.
One that is I think sustained
not just by the popularity
of these big retailers, though that too,
but also really by the
infrastructural role
that they have come to play
in the lives of many citizens.
So thank you very much.
I'm looking forward to your question.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you so much.
So we have plenty of time for Q&A.
We have until 5:30.
So let's open the floor for questions
and maybe we can give a chance
to students first couple of questions.
Any students from EP&A or
political science (indistinct)?
Hi, Amy.
- Like, you kind of
mentioned near the end there,
there's that paradoxical relationship
that exists where a lot of,
like, lower income people
are simultaneously hurt by
the big retailers that exist,
but also sort of depend on 'em
in order to get basic goods
and necessities and things like that.
What do you think the
most, like, actionable way
like, is to move forward and, you know,
like, be able to solve the fact
that these low income people
stop getting corrupted
by these large retailers,
but also still have access
to basic necessities and things like that?
- Okay, great, thank you.
It's a great question.
So policy, I mean, my whole
message is that policy
and politics got us into
this deep equilibrium,
and I believe that policy and politics
are the way out of this bind as well.
I don't have a ton of faith
in solutions like kind of
collective self-restraint
on the part of consumers.
I think sort of everything,
all the work that I've
ever done on platforms,
this and other kinds of platforms,
doesn't give me a whole
lot of faith that just,
you know, sort of asking
consumers to sort of like,
don't do it, isn't gonna get us very far.
And so, you know, my
friend, Jenny Mansbridge,
has a theory of, you
know, legitimate coercion.
The role of government is to pass policies
that involve legitimate
coercion sort to force,
to use policy to force people to do things
that they wouldn't otherwise do,
and to place, you know,
sort of solve societal
collective action problems
through policy.
And so the two that I
would point to would be,
first of all, I think
antitrust legislation
is really important.
And I think that, I mean, I
basically agree with Lina Khan,
who's currently the head of FTC,
that these are structural problems.
They require structural solutions.
I think the EU has shown
the way in some areas
of how to restrain some
of these big sellers
in terms of, like, limits
on predatory pricing,
limits on discriminatory
treatment and things like that.
It's still in development,
but I think there are models there.
And then, you know, I'm a labor scholar.
And so labor law reform
is absolutely essential.
So one of the things that
I try to do in the book is,
and I didn't have time to do in the talk,
is I compare the labor,
you know, the situation
in the retail market in European
countries and in the US.
And you know, in all of these countries,
you know, retail workers
are not very well organized,
but in Europe, they're far better covered
by collective contracts that,
you know, regulate wages,
that regulate working hours, that provide,
you know, some of these
core foundational rights
that in this country are seen as, like,
fringe benefits or
something that you might get
if your employer is sort
of particularly generous
or something like that.
So, yeah, those would be the two,
and especially labor law reform,
I just think that it's
absolutely critical.
And again, we have, you know,
it's a moment of labor activism
and so I have actually quite a lot of hope
that things could move in
that direction as well.
- [Man] So returning to the point you made
about political mobilization
and the ability of these retailers
to kind of leverage
their essential services
to, you know, generate goodwill
that they can call upon,
you know, in moments of, you
know, potential regulation.
I'm wondering if you
think that contemporarily,
we're kind of running up
against the limits of that
and that it seems like the
capacity of corporations
to kind of, in that way
leverage public support
against regulations seem reduced
and that kind of challenges
to vote in terms of,
like, racial antitrust,
but also in terms of, you
know, legal organizing.
They seem,
and this is anecdotal but,
like, increasingly successful
and kind of challenging
them despite the fact that,
you know, you have a
corporation like Amazon
that kind of makes it
explicit that business model
is dependent on low-wage labor.
And so I'm wondering
about, like, the
contemporary possibilities
for challenging retailers
despite this history
of kind of goodwill
and this sense of kind of
belovedness among population
- Right.
One of the things that's distinctive
and that's different about
Europe versus the United States,
thanks for coming, Amy.
One of the things that's different
is that there are very few
sort of countervailing forces,
organized interests countervailing
that are capable of
countervailing the power
of these monopolists or
would-be monopolists, right?
So it's like they can develop
this direct relationship
to consumers because
there are very few sort
of intermediary organizations
that can sort of perform
countervailing functions.
And so, you know, unions would be one,
these are associations that
have actually a presence
and that have performed
countervailing functions in Europe,
but that are sort of absent
or extremely weak in the United States.
And so I've already talked about labor.
The other one, I would say, is
actually trade associations,
organized employers,
because in a lot of the
work that I've done on,
again, on these platforms,
especially platforms that kind of move in
and come to dominate
and often are doing so
by working in sort of gray areas
or sort of even illegally to begin
and just kind of paying these
fines and stuff like that.
One of the most important
countervailing forces
in many European countries is
organized employer interests,
because organized employers
also don't have a big interest
in some firm gaining a
foothold in the market.
And they would much prefer
sort of, especially those
who have sort of monopolistic
ambitions, right?
So they are often defenders
of a well-regulated market.
One that certainly sort of,
certainly puts up some barriers
to the kinds of illegal
or sort of semi-legal
tactics that are often used
in the early phases in
order to gain scale.
So this is, again, one of
the, I think, casualties
of American antitrust
because, you know, going all the way back
to the late 19th century,
what we know is that the American,
I mean, the story that
everybody kind of, I think,
knows is that antitrust
was used against unions.
And one of the reasons
that unions are so weak
is because unions organized
on a more industrial level
were sort of disarticulated partly
because they were constantly
facing conspiracy charges
and so forth.
Another big casualty of that period
that people don't talk as much
about is trade associations.
Trade associations were very
much enfeebled in this period
because the courts in the United States,
again, distinctively
and very unlike what
was going on in Europe,
courts in the United States
were extremely averse,
were extremely negative toward any form
of horizontal coordination
among small competitors.
It's to do with the
period that I talked about
when Brandeis was saying,
well, shouldn't we let
these small competitors,
so to coordinate their
activities in order to,
you know, be able to hold their own
against these dominant players.
And he was actually an advocate
of something like would've been,
you know, stronger trade associations.
And they really atrophied in this country.
And they atrophied because while antitrust
was very forbearing toward large,
you know, conglomerate kinds of companies,
because with everything organized,
all the functions organized
within a single entity,
there's no collusion,
there's no conspiracy,
but as soon as there was any kind
of horizontal coordination,
whether by unions,
whether by workers, or by small retailers
or small businesses,
that actually ran afoul
of American antitrust.
And so, you know, fast
forward to the present,
those are exactly the kinds
of countervailing forces
that are actually more
effective, I would say,
politically than sort of organized
or sort of collective self-restraint
on the part of consumers who have, like,
you know, for whom sort of
collective action problems
are just, like, insurmountable.
Oh, should I do something?
- I had a question about what you think,
what effect technology's gonna have, like,
specifically on, I'm thinking
about just, like, trends
in e-commerce and how expensive it is
to have the digital infrastructure
and logistics for that,
which obviously will
make it harder to compete
for smaller retailers,
but also in terms of labor
and potentially being
able to cut costs on that,
like, using AI or other
forms of technology
and whether you think that's something
that can be regulated.
- Well, yeah, I mean the data
is really crucial to these big platforms,
you know, or these big
retailers generally,
sort of Walmart as well.
And it does two things, like,
there's always been a
kind of balance of power
and a kind of tension.
You'd think that mass retail
and mass manufacturing
would kind of go together.
They'd be sort of symbiotically
related to one another,
but in fact at many points,
they've really been at
loggerheads with one another
over things like pricing.
And so the balance of power
has shifted very much in
favor of large retailers,
who now have the data
to be able to dictate to their suppliers.
You know, they know when,
you know, what is selling at what price,
in combination with what other
things, in what locations.
And so they're able to really use that
to dominate the suppliers and vendors
that they get the goods from.
So the use of technology,
that's something that has
really bounded to the benefit
of these big retailers.
And the same thing with labor.
Brishen Rogers has just
written a wonderful book
on the way in which these big companies,
not just, you know, Walmart and Amazon,
although those two also,
is used to surveil workers,
is used to control workers,
and is used to sort of speed up, you know,
sort of accelerate work in
various ways in that, you know,
that is coded in the United
States under current antitrust
or at least Chicago school
antitrust thinking as efficient,
but that is in fact
extraordinarily exploitative.
And so, so far I would say that the data
that the sort of the
technology has operated
to tilt the balance of power
further in favor of retailers,
both vis-a-vis manufacturers
and vis-a-vis workers.
Can you do something about that?
Yeah, and again, I mean,
I hate to keep saying,
but the EU is actually doing
some stuff in that regard
that protects, that sort
of places some limits
on the extent to which these big retailers
can use their access to data in order to,
I don't know, cannibalize,
like, for Amazon,
there's a rule that limits their ability
to cannibalize their third party sellers.
Like, Amazon has this strategy
where if they see something,
because they have the data,
if they see something is
selling particularly well,
they'll jump in and do
an Amazon basic knockoff
of that product.
And so there's some limits on that.
And similarly, one of the things
that's pretty foundational
to labor law in most of Europe
is limitations on the use
of data to surveil workers.
You can certainly can't surveil them
when it comes to organizing activities
and you also can't surveil them
in terms of their sort of
the everyday pace of work.
So, again, I think so far it hasn't worked
that way in the US, but that's, again,
policy, politics could
re-equilibrate things
at least a little bit.
- [Woman] But then, I
think you can (indistinct)
- [Woman] Hi, thank you so much.
Premise, I'm from Europe
and perhaps because of
that I'm not so positive
about the part of the
world that I come from.
And I'm wondering whether
you think that Europe
will be going in the
same direction of the US
because while,
like, we obviously have a
very strong welfare state
in certain countries
of the European Union.
In particular in the south,
we are so severely underpaid
that we necessarily have
to rely on big retailers.
So if you gave the same speech,
I work at the European
University Institute,
most people, most PhD
will be amongst those
who are so severely underpaid
that we cannot really afford
to be the consumer who chooses
between different things.
And while it's true that
EU is doing certain things
like AI act will regulate the control
that retailers can have and
digital data, et cetera,
but there are other norms that still,
especially regarding consumption
that have a very strong market bias
and that are using, as a legal basis,
the integration of the internal market,
and that is pushing for
massive consumption.
If you read even the new proposals
on sustainable consumption,
it's almost ironic
because the summaries and the recital says
that having a variety of
products constantly circulating
within the internal market
is still Europe's number one priority.
So that pushes towards
this type of consumption.
So I'm curious to know
whether you're positive
as what will happen to you
or whether we are coming closer to you.
- It's certainly the case
that, yeah, absolutely.
There are certainly trends
that I signaled this,
but I didn't maybe talk enough about it.
There's certainly trends in Europe
that are sort of converging
on the American model
of consumption in some ways.
I will say, and there are
certain ways in which,
you know, some of these constraints
that I was talking about,
like shopping hours,
I mean when it comes to e-commerce,
shopping hours is like imaginal line
that is, like, long since
been breached, right?
There's no limit as to when and how
and where people can shop, right?
And so I absolutely take your point.
I do think that there has
been some convergence.
I do still see though, that
there are bigger differences
in terms of union coverage,
even, you know, like, no other country,
in no other country do
workers have to organize
on a firm by firm basis, right?
You have more encompassing
collective bargaining agreements,
you have a stronger welfare state.
And so, you know, there's a
more solid floor, I would say,
partly because the reservation wage.
You just can't pay people,
you know, two cents
in order to perform certain tasks,
where the floor in the United States,
so far at least, has been just much lower.
But I absolutely take your point,
And, you know, I don't
mean to say that Europe
hasn't developed a very
vibrant consumer culture.
I also see that, you know, discounters
have made inroads in Europe, absolutely.
Many of them are actually,
they took their lessons
from the United States,
like Carrefour, which is the
biggest discounter in France,
was founded by this guy
who had just come from the United States,
you know, having just
freshly completed an MBA
and went and opened Carrefour.
You also have hard discounters
in countries like Germany
that have spread, especially
in the food sector.
So Aldi, Lidl, these are these
so-called hard discounters
that are just really low prices,
also virtually no staffing.
I mean, Trader Joe's actually belongs to,
it was bought by Aldi.
So, you know, if you were
shopping at Trader Joe's,
that's actually an Aldi,
extension of Aldi.
So I absolutely think that
that's definitely going on.
So far, it has been in certain sectors,
you know, much more intense
than in other sectors.
I would say, in the grocery sector,
it's been especially intense.
What maybe is different about the US
is that it's so spread across
all product categories,
so to speak.
- Should I, anybody?
- [Woman] Students?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Professors.
Ian.
- Yeah, so I found this
really fascinating.
I just wonder if isn't a
missing piece in the sort of,
that goes to uniqueness of
the Amazon business model,
which is, my reading the history
is sort of the big box stores,
the Walmarts and the Sears
and the Woolworths, they
put out neighborhood stores
and they also curtailed a
lot of small manufacturing
and small services.
So, you know, the
neighborhood hardware store
would also fix people's
shoes and cut keys,
all of that stuff went to
the Walmarts and so on.
And Amazon is putting
the big box stores out
of business, right?
I mean it's the Toys"R"Us, it's the Sears,
those are the people that
are being shut down by Amazon
because they are strictly retail
and you see it where
they go global as well.
So if you look at, like, India,
where Walmart tried to go into India,
they ran into a lot of
opposition from very small,
you know, suppliers
and suppliers of retail
services and manufacturing.
Amazon is a huge success
in India very quickly
because they're almost
like, you know, eBay there.
I mean all these little suppliers
can just sell on Amazon.
And so it does seem to
me, it's a different,
maybe this is just yet
another stage or something,
but it does seem like there
was this piece not there
in your talk.
So what you have to say about that?
- Yeah, so I should have talked more
about Amazon since it was
so prominent in the title.
So that's the piece that I've,
everybody I think knows,
but in fact to link it up is important.
First of all, just Walmart
also famously flamed out
of the German market and
partly because of labor,
they weren't cooperating with labor
and labor wasn't gonna
cooperate with them.
Yeah, so Walmart, I mean Amazon
is the next phase of this, so to speak.
And one of the things
that I try to point out
is that there's a way in which,
you know, people think that Amazon is,
like, this whole new phenomenon.
And there are certain ways
in which what Amazon is doing
is totally different from
these previous big box stores.
Like, big box stores, they're big,
but ultimately the selection is limited
to the amount of shelf
space that they have.
Amazon has no such boundaries, right?
That's one thing.
The second thing is that-
- [Man] No walk-in.
- And no walk-in.
Well, that's the other thing.
It makes purchasing frictionless.
It's totally frictionless,
especially if you get your
product in the buy box,
then literally if you press the button,
then the product is on the way.
It also is very distinctive
in the sense that, you know,
in order to get into these big box stores,
your product already has
to be popular, right?
You can't get space on an Amazon shelf
unless you already have a following.
Whereas in Amazon, it's sort of,
what they call long tail retailing.
It's like they could sell
even the most obscure things,
the most niche product
that only one person wants.
They can, you know, sell used
things right along new things.
So in all those ways,
there's something really
quite new about Amazon,
but what I also am trying to
emphasize in this book, really,
is that there's so much of this strategy
that really draws on a very old playbook,
an old playbook in terms
of the business strategy,
thin, you know, low margins,
thin, you know, sort of high volume sales,
and also the political playbook that,
you know, the way that
they rose to dominance.
And so what I didn't tell here,
but what, you know, is
definitely worth telling
and is talked about in the book
is how Amazon itself
used regulatory arbitrage
in order to sort of grow to scale.
So, like, Walmart grew very methodically,
you know, he found, you know,
Sam Walton founded a store
here and then he would,
you know, circle that
store with a few others
and kind of build out from there.
The Amazon model was completely different.
It was much closer to Amazon, you know,
just scale up as fast as possible,
you know, blanket the country
and profitless growth for a long time.
But a lot of it is
really the old playbook.
It's like labor, you know,
labor law violations,
low wages, a lot of
temporary contract workers,
you know, a lot of regulatory
arbitrage in the early years.
One of Amazon's huge
advantages was that they,
you know, got around state tax laws
by locating in countries or
in states that had low taxes
and then shipping to places
that had higher taxes.
I mean, the Supreme Court
finally closed that loophole,
but sort of, like, the story
that I'm telling, you know,
it was way later.
By that time Amazon had grown to scale
and by that time they had, you know,
a lot of people who had come
to organize their shopping
habits around this retailer.
So I do wanna say that there is something,
that Amazon is not
something out of brand new
and the technology is
interesting and everything,
but a lot of what they're doing
is really kind of goes back
to old strategies.
And I mean, you know, like,
Sears back in the day,
they had the high tech warehouses.
And what was high tech at that time?
Well, it was pneumatic tubes that sent,
you know, messages around the factory
and now it's robots and pickers.
And so I wanna kind of play around
with the strand that really, you know,
how we got to this kind
of crescendo of Amazon.
And who knows if Amazon
is the last, you know,
chapter in the story?
- [Woman] Yeah, so thank you for coming,
really engaged in talking,
excited to read the book,
but I was really interested in this point
about retailers exploiting
public infrastructure
for private gains.
And specifically two questions,
one, pertaining to what
aspects about the US
made these large
retailers able to exploit,
like, USPS services,
like, more so than retailers
in other countries?
Is it just, like, a consequence of,
like, US being a much larger country
with, like, a greater proportion
of the population in rural.
And then secondly, how in
the internet age specifically
are retailers continuing
to exploit this public infrastructure
for their own personal gain?
- Oh, great questions.
So take the postal service question first.
So these cooperatives that I
was talking about in Europe,
they often also had credit
unions attached to them.
And those credit unions were
a source of capital also
to grow the co-ops.
Credit unions in this country
were basically boxed out until 1921,
was the first time you
got any credit union
at the state level, and
it was in Massachusetts.
And they were boxed out by state bankers,
state level bankers who
didn't want the competition.
And so the US Postal
system was kind of became,
you know, it wasn't
designed for that purpose,
but that was gonna sort
of serve the same function
as the cooperatives
would've had already kind
of in-house at that time.
And how did they continue to
exploit public infrastructure?
I would say a lot of ways.
One is just this dependence on
food stamps and SNAP benefits
and the dependence on public,
social benefits, right?
That underwrites a low wage economy.
You don't have to pay
workers if they, you know,
you don't have to provide benefits,
it sort of lowers the floor.
And those low wages are,
in a fact, subsidized by,
by public social benefits.
And the other way is, you know,
like, just the infrastructure of the,
you know, the entire infrastructure,
like, Walmart, for example,
depends enormously on,
you know, trucking, right?
And they were huge beneficiaries
of the deregulation of trucking.
Again, it was something
that they didn't cause,
but they certainly promoted
the deregulation of trucking,
which used to be a very unionized,
a unionized sector.
And that over time became
completely deregulated,
such that the salaries of truckers
are now really basically
subsistence wage salaries.
And so, you know, the public
infrastructure, you know,
Walmart depends entirely on the highways
and these truckers that are
delivering all these goods,
or independent contractors
who are dependent on,
you know, sort of these
government programs
to support their families.
So I mean those are
just a few of the ways.
- [Woman] We have time
for me one more question.
- [Man] So I haven't shopped
on Amazon since 2017,
when I read Lina Khan's piece,
and I agree that consumer
choice is not the way out of it,
this problem, but I was wondering,
when you were talking
about kind of solutions,
it seems to me,
part of the thought in the talk
is that there's a difference
between cooperation
and concentration in antitrust regulation
that might be relevant.
I guess I just know American antitrust law
is a kind of foreign distinction to me,
and I'm was trying to
wrap my head around it.
And it seems to me one way
that I might understand it,
is that price competition
is maybe not what we want
in a market so much as quality competition
and innovation competition,
which is why it's okay
for a bunch of small
producers to get together
to maybe keep prices higher
than they would otherwise be,
but they're gonna compete on other ways.
I suspect that is maybe
not a distortion of the way
that you would think about
it, but I guess I'm curious
because largely, how do you think
about differentiating
cooperation and concentration,
and is there some kind of,
do we need to stop thinking
about prices in the economy
as a way of measuring whether
we're doing things better
or building a better economy?
- So that's a great question.
It's a complicated question,
but the short answer is,
prices, yeah, shouldn't
be the only metric,
because when you think
about consumer welfare,
you could even think about,
you know, innovation,
quality, et cetera.
And these are all things
that are valued differently
in other countries.
I will say, and I have a paper
on this if you want more,
but, you know, there is a
really important difference
between, antitrust breaks out
into two things just crudely
that are pretty distinct.
One is, like, you know,
what is the attitude
toward vertical concentration,
on mergers and things like
that, and vertical dominance
or the ability of big powerful companies
to dominate more, you
know, sort of those players
that are reliant on them?
And then there's horizontal coordination.
In general, and I'm gonna
sort of say this very crudely,
but it's more complicated.
In general, American antitrust
has always been extremely
strict against any form
of horizontal coordination.
That's where Europe has
always been different
and it remains different despite the fact
that European antitrust
has evolved a little bit
in the direction of the US.
On many forms of coordination
among non-dominant players
are seen as competition enhancing rather
than, per se, illegal, okay?
Vertical, I mean the US has
always been kind of forbearing
on vertical restraints, right?
And so now all of the attention
or a lot of the attention in
sort of revising antitrust law
in this country, I think it's good
but it focuses almost exclusively
on the issue of abusive dominance.
And I think that's absolutely
a half of the picture,
but the other half of the picture
would be to talk about
greater forbearance vis-a-vis
in terms of coordination
among non-dominant players,
because I think that is
actually really important
unless you think that the government
can do all of this on its own.
I really think that the
growing countervailing forces
is really quite crucial
to kind of sustaining
competition over the longer run.
But there's more to be said.
- Thank you so much, Professor Thelen,
for this insightful lecture,
and everyone, for attending.
(audience applauds)
(bright music)